lui versé 78 rock j fois le choc de
milieu de tableau de division honneur a
tenu toutes ses promesses
après une grosse bataille dans la
possession le stade roger couderc de
montigny le bretonneux a finalement vu
les visiteurs s'imposer dans les
derniers instants du match
ce qu'en finale à 18 à 17 h au c'est pas
compliqué ils ont fait un très beau
match
ils ont joué comme il fallait à
l'extérieur ils ont réussi à prendre le
score et derrière ils ont des bons
augures human qui ont bien joué et bien
bien géré bien gérer les temps forts
temps faibles et du coup bas à la fin ça
joue à rien mais c'est pour eux je ne
vais pas un mauvais match en effet dès
qu'on se crée les occasions pour pour
aller au bout il ya eu plein de petites
erreurs dans des zones de marque qui
nous coûte cher parce que l'arrivée on
meurt à un point alors qu'on aurait dû
beaucoup plus scoré pour pour faire moi
qui vaut deux et qui peut donc
effectivement on fait une belle
prestation et on a failli passer à la
trappe à d'ailleurs la dernière minute
ils ont menés de huit points à cinq
minutes de la fin puis on se fait en se
faisant remonter quand même donc mais on
n'a pas perdu pied on est allé jusqu'à
la fête jusqu'au bout de la constatation
de la lucidité pour aller rechercher les
points qu'il fallait malgré cette
défaite lui verser 60 18 prend le point
de bonus défensif les saint quentinois
se retrouve troisième du championnat
avec 23 points 5 victoires depuis le
début de la saison un bilan inattendue
après huit journées pour ce club issu
d'une fusion entre le sky rugby et
montigny le bretonneux
il était très positif avant le match un
peu moins aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est une fusion si donc un
groupe est en train de se créer donc
c'est aussi des matches comme ça qui
nous permet de renforcer ce groupe
l'objectif déjà c'était sportif à la
base on se prend un petit peu au jeu
maintenant et finir dans les quatre
premiers
ça va être dur mais faut être ambitieux
prochain match pour lui et ses 78 le
dimanche 8 décembre sur le terrain de la
nuit une équipe de bas de tableau de
division honneur